we're gonna we're gonna talk about we're
gonna talk about a combination of things
this story says state agency rules
against Li couple who let Sun play
outside so I don't know what this kids
four years old okay so look the state
Division of Human Rights has ruled
against the Long Island family who said
they were singled out and threatened by
their condo association for letting
their four-year-old son play outside
now some people are claiming it's like a
race thing I don't know and I'm not
super concerned because first I do think
four might be a little too young but was
he doing riding his bike up and down the
sidewalk yeah here's the the main reason
I want to talk about this I think I've
heard this over and over again and I've
been kind of shocked by this when I was
a little kid my mom would be like I bet
I'm gonna go play Angie or actually know
my parents about go out and play and
come back when the lights come on and so
when the streetlights would turn on in
the south side of Chicago that's when we
would know to come home yeah and we'd be
home with him in a few minutes so I
would go out and explore and I'm like
seven or eight years old mm-hmm riding
my bike up and down gonna mile plus
there were stories that I've been told
from like my older family about how they
used to just go on adventures as far as
they possibly could when there were
little kids
yeah I remember that and now we're
seeing stories like this where it's like
what's that you let your child ride his
bike his tricycle out in front of your
house
I mean you've lived in New York right
yeah so I lived in New York for a long
time and I've had Brydon the subway and
I see a little seven year olds get on by
themselves coming home from school eight
year old yep selling candy like like oh
you're a little kid are you by yourself
like yeah yeah you are like huh yeah
okay when I was what's so wrong with
that when I was like 9 or 10 I would
take the subway from the south side the
orange line yeah take it to the loop
transfer to the red line take that to
Wrigleyville
where my mom my family owned a cafe
briefly we're not a business we didn't
really it didn't make it a lot of loans
to get that thing going and that was
when I was a little kid I was like nine
at nine from between like nine and ten
years old
but I mean it's not for you know this is
a four I know I know I know but like
he's riding his trike in front of his
house that's also true during I was
seven I got onto a plane and I left the
state that I lived in and I flew to the
state that my grandparents lived in I
actually did that to you
yeah with my unaccompanied Meyer come
down like sign something I didn't cause
any trouble nobody cause me any trouble
they show me what do you think happens
when the kids aren't allowed to leave
bubble world and I don't I don't mean
bubbles like echo chamber I mean like
zero these are like bubble kids they're
right out it's it's the kids right
outside it's like isn't that the
backyard as well so front yard so I'm a
condo so it's what is the yard it's like
he's playing in the yard I guess right
so I don't know exactly why they're
saying you can't have your four-year-old
playing outside by themselves outside of
because I I think you know the first
it's about the condominiums rules so I
don't want to conflate you know what I'm
saying about bad parents and nanny
states turning children into whiny
losers for this of their lives
I want to conflate that with this
because this might just be like the
condo association has a rules and its
might be a different thing yeah but when
did the rules end like we were talking
about last week the six-year-old got
arrested right exactly they were
throwing a tantrum and the mom the
parents didn't even weren't even
notified yeah two days the kid got sent
to a cyclo cursing you know that's a law
that they can just take up you know what
you're you're being crazy I'm gonna
throw you in a psych ward because we can
talk on your parents so here's what
here's what basically happened earlier
we were we were talking about this story
and then it's like you know little kid
goes outside parents get in trouble and
I've seen tons of stories like this
there was one where there was there was
a story around a while ago of like a
seven-year-old who was playing outside
by themselves and the neighbor called
the police the police showed up and saw
the kid playing and so they were like
where's your parents and then like tried
claiming it was negligence that the kid
was playing by themselves like this is
where we're at schools in Chicago are
locking kids in solitary because they're
having temper tantrums yeah in Florida
that girl gets little six-year-old girl
gets arrested and now we have the story
of a condo fining the people who live
there because they let their for your
play outside by themself yeah what do
you thinks gonna happen to these kids
when they grow up
when they never get exposed to the real
world or I guess in the case of solitary
confinement those kids are gonna have
like PTSD and weird traumatic disorders
from through those solitary is torture
man no they're like padded rooms right
yeah yeah lobbying kids so I'm not too
confident in the next generation so
think about this for all of the whiny
loser Millennials who are offended by
literally every
thing every multiply that by a hundred
and what you know what really annoys me
is that they're not even in a place that
they are offended themselves it's like
they're doing this justice warrior thing
you know they're offended because
someone else may be offended
no they're pretending someone else may
be offended well it's like you know what
if if there's gonna be someone who's
offended let that person actually be
offended and then maybe speak then no
but but but even that it's like I get
what you're saying you know I'm saying
like don't be offended on my behalf
yeah exactly but but this is what
they're turning into because well so
here's what I think it is those people
you're talking about exist because we
started that seed a long time ago of
selfishness yeah okay here's what I
think I think when you look at the the
like the moon landing boy was America
excited and unified as far as I know
because I'm not old enough I was in a
live back then but but they portray it
that way though right ask not what the
country your country can do for you ask
what you can do for your country
today it's literally the don't you know
it's it's asked not what you can do if
your country its demand things you
demand your country take things from
other people and give to you yeah so
what I you know I'm looking at these
stories about these kids and you know I
think it's happening and all I see is my
of like V for Vendetta
when he says all of the pieces he starts
explaining how everything started to
coming and coming together and he said
understanding it started with a virus
didn't it well take take no no take a
bunch of people who are selfish make a
bunch people are selfish who say it's
all for me what ends up happening is
they don't want to watch kids they don't
want to deal with the kids they don't
want to deal with being responsible
parents you know so they think you know
what whatever it is you're doing is
causing you problems arrest the kid lock
them in a room those kids then grow up
becoming extremely selfish and and
separated from unity so community is
fracturing a part in a million different
ways and everyone is so says like but
but but think about this Millennials
aren't getting married they're not
having kids they don't want to have kids
they write articles all day about how
having cats and not having kids is
better we found the Facebook group for
parents who wish that they hadn't had
kids and I'm like what do you do they're
like a support group no it's like I I
wish that I had kids
have kids I don't like having kids why
do I have kids and your and I'm like
you're a bunch of Millennials who are
raised to feel special or you have a
bunch of participation prizes and now
that you have to take really
responsibility it turns out that it's
kind of hard you don't like it there's a
Expedia commercial I saw yeah have you
seen this one yeah it's these two girls
pushing like sitting apart pushing their
daughter on the on a swing and they're
like oh look at this beep you know she's
at the beach like why is she at work
here yeah and then Captain Obvious is
like condoms it's just like what dude
because right you're responsible she was
responsible you know what you weren't
you know people had kids mmm for
themselves and for their communities
it's like but we are now in this world
where Millennials have no idea why they
would ever have a family this is crazy
to me it's a it's nuts what are you
gonna do when you're 80 there and ask
the government to do it for them but
there's not gonna be a younger
generation so we're seeing this weird
bubble effect where like in Japan
there's more older people than young
people because they stopped having kids
right it's all becoming about me what I
want when I need a me and no one's doing
anything for each other and the craziest
thing to me about all this is the rise
of these young socialists mm-hmm they're
not socialists because they actually
care about community they're socialists
because it's they're lazy and they want
things given today want it to be easy so
I know we did kind of start with you yep
it's it's they make you think we're here
because we have empathy want to help
other people no it's because you want
everything done for you exactly the way
it has been hey I'll tell you what
though socialism will be a rude
awakening for these people when all
sudden they're giving everything and
working twice as hard yeah they're like
why am i giving everything away oh
that's what you wanted right no I under
the special one yeah that's it you know
it's so crazy to me is look I I want to
go back to us I know we started on like
kids being you know arrested or like not
be allowed to play no this is how it
starts these kids then grow up they they
have no you know reality no mindset of
reality they've never actually done with
hardship and this little kid who went
outside
and the parents got in trouble their
parents aren't the authority anymore
that's true so so when I was right yeah
no this is something Jonathan hi talks
about when you get to college and you're
like well I have to talk to my professor
I have to talk to administration if
something goes wrong you appeal directly
to the power over you forget about your
parents forget about taking your own
responsibilities no but what I what I
mean is think about what happens when
you're a little kid hmm and your parents
are saying I'm the boss here's what you
need to do which they're not really
doing and then all of a sudden a cop
shows up and says nope and then you go
yeah yeah ha ha you end up with all
these little kids who are like I'm
smarter I'm better I'm special I get
whatever I want they grow up and become
these outraged fake offended people who
demand socialism because I'm special and
I deserve it all I'll call CPS on you if
you try to discipline yep dude let me
let me tell you this great story you're
gonna love this story okay I was in New
York City near 30 rock this was in like
20 early 2016 and a bunch of protesters
showed up for pro Bernie Sanders and
they were like chanting and stuff all of
a sudden some dude out of nowhere runs
right up to him starts yelling drop drop
Trump and he's like you're throwing his
arms in the air one of the protesters
walks over to a lady cop and she goes
excuse me ma'am can you arrest him I kid
you not I'm not exaggerating she said
can you arrest him then the cop goes for
what and she's like he's harassing us
and the lady was like he's just yelling
Trump and she and the protester goes
yeah but we're here in support of Bernie
and he's harassing us and then the cop
goes have you noticed how you're yelling
Bernie and and she's like yeah and he
goes and he's yelling Trump and she like
right and he's like the lady cop was am
I gonna arrest you both for the same
thing and then she was like I'm gonna
call your supervisor and the lady cop
starts laughing and she goes okay do it
I was I was I was standing right there
watching and I'm laughing like yo what
are these people whoever you are you are
my hero talking to you lady is amazing
these whiny entitled brats man they want
equality but only if it's favours them
but so think about what really happens
like I kid you not experience this woman
thinking she had a right to protest on
the other guy didn't ya I guess he was
saying Trump and she was saying Bernie
so she thought she could go to the
authority and they would do what she
said right so think about what happens
how dare you not do what I just told you
to do these so many people like that
blows me away so you have kids who have
never experienced hardship now they're
soft and scared you know either snow
plow parents or the authority has
punished their parents taking away any
content of a concept of authority right
so like for me when I grew up my dad was
the boss my mom was the boss you you you
honor and respect your parents yeah I
went to Catholic school for a little bit
too and that's you know you have the
command honor that honor thy father and
thy mother and so for me it was like I
mean that's why man pay attention to
yeah but I can't imagine you know if
you're growing up and all of a sudden
someone comes up to you and says you
don't have to listen to your parents
yeah you literally grow up with no view
of anyone having respectful Authority
and you end up just being a whiny baby
who demands everything from everyone
else but they're gonna get shocked you
know when when the system actually comes
in and it's fair you know what I mean
yeah but but what is the world comin to
it's coming to a bunch of you know when
he loses I guess that's the kind of the
gist of it cuz we were we were we were
talking about you know kids getting
arrested we talked about it before and
then we started talking about offensive
comment but it's a culprit it's the
culprit like you know and you know the
people who are seeing that kid out there
you know what are they thinking you know
that were they thinking that the kid's
gonna get kidnapped or something it's
like it's a condo right so when when
that story of the neighbor who called
the cops because the seven girls playing
outside yeah that's the entitled I'm
smarter and I'm better than you attitude
yeah and said it's it's so weird because
so I'm gonna call the authorities to
have this kid or have these people get
in trouble for having their kid play
you're saying no I mean it's kind of
paradoxical now because that seems like
overbearing control of like do you
actually care about the kid when you do
that or is it because you want to appear
like you're better than everyone else
yeah justice warrior that's right Sam
old people who are like those Warriors
men they should have been watching their
kid yeah exactly yeah that person's not
doing life
to my standards which is fear going to
virtue signal about so-so right well so
so here I was gonna say here's where we
here's why we this conversation came up
basically cuz Adam made an offensive
joke which he won't repeat because no
you can't say certain things you can't
but privately we're all laughing at how
offensive it was it was pretty offensive
yeah good good um but you know so apt
him after Adams makes us very offensive
joke he's like hey you're laughing at it
and I said yeah but it's because we're
confident like this stuff doesn't faze
us yeah that's that's right I don't get
it I get offended like if I get offended
I'm it's kind of just like I'm not a fan
of that and that's the end of it I don't
owe ya my god I don't cry I mentioned
earlier that I was in the comments and
every day like you guys would mention my
name and the comments would like flurry
about different things about me and my
bro oh my god the comment you guys make
me laugh so much I really I get such a
kick out of reading the comment they're
so funny oh man well so I could take it
I'm confident I know who I am
yeah right nothing anyone says is gonna
change how that I feel like so about
myself I'm confident somebody somebody
called you soy brow and said something
like I like like not wanting on the show
or whatever I'm sorry you started
laughing about it yeah and I was like
that's exactly it
there's like two different groups of
people in this culture war there are
people who you know harumph i say how
dare you call me the name and other
people who are like 'no that's pretty
funny yeah like you you like you can
call me whatever you want i don't know
for the record they were cracking up
both both of these two we're we're
cracking up it was good bad joke
i thought it was funny being able to
have your own concept of yourself yeah
nothing that's important it doesn't
matter what people call no I didn't
always have that though yeah it took me
a long time to figure that out it took
me a lot of emotional intelligence it's
hard that we discussed a couple weeks
ago and it's like without that you know
and we're not being taught that and the
parents aren't being taught that and
they're certainly not teaching their
kids that you know dude so people have
to go find it on their own
that's so the problem going back to it
yeah
saying earlier about the the Facebook
page of parents who are like I regret
having kids yeah first of all it was
always a story about between like years
one through five I'm like did you not
read a book about those being the harder
years of raising kids right right but it
was but it's but yeah it's also a it's
it's these people who are realizing but
what about me yeah my life I don't get
to live my life anymore it's like yeah
because you had a kid yeah it's not even
that it's like dude when that kid when
you're 80 and then kids you know 55 or
60 you're gonna be so happy you made
that investment man it's all about what
was it on Family Guy Peter goes to
council a bunch of addicts this was one
of the jokes and he was like here I
can't say I can't say the jokes I really
really can't it's Family Guy it's kind
of crazy I can't but one of the things
it says is here's something that all you
should all do have as many kids as
possible because then you increase the
chances they become celebrities in
Hollywood but that's like a funny way of
actually phrasing like listen and then
they'll take care of you you you write
exactly read writing but where are you
gonna be without a family gonna be old
and like are you you're gonna be
sleeping in our bridge yeah and you're
gonna have no one there for you family
is an investment into yourself in your
community but but what you think about
how people don't care about America
that's the key though family not just
kids family is the investment you know
exactly it's like you can have kids and
just be an a-hole to them and they can
hate you and then you can never have a
relationship right or you can join a
hate group right exactly and then your
kid finds out one day and they're like
what you're in this group that says I
wish I never had kids
yes right you're called a hate group
right so it's like you know sure the kid
what if the kid finds it one day and
then like disowns you and then there
goes that investment dude there there
there was like an article written it I
think was like Washington Post where I
was like I regret having kids and on
Twitter went viral they were like
seriously delete this your kids are
gonna grow up and are gonna see this
exactly yeah that's crazy it's the
opposite of these stories of like these
young young people who are like my
mother refused to have an abortion and
that's like the story Tebow was that him
yeah there was there was one viral tick
tock of a young woman who was her arm
wasn't developing in the womb and she
said when she was
when she was in the womb she had she's
missing her right arm go should the
doctor told her mom get an abortion and
her mom was like absolutely not
yeah and this girl's like I've bound the
planet for basically over 17 years and
I'm glad that my mom didn't do it yeah
and then she yells Trump 2020 but that's
not the point the point is like it's
like the inversion of that yeah it's
crazy
I couldn't imagine growing up and then
like finding old articles of my parents
being like I hate my child he's awful
I'd be like whoa dude exactly that's
what they're doin stuff yeah well I
heard work doesn't go away that stays
with you and that brings me back to that
commercial of what we were talking about
yeah because those women made a choice
that mean that yeah they have to be at
home during the winter with their kids
I'm sorry but they're begging
responsible no but the the photos of
people at the beach it's fake yeah it's
true
this has always been so annoying to me I
can't stand this about people I remember
back in the day with like MySpace and
Facebook you'd see photos of people and
they're like looking all sassy and
they're like standing by the cliffside
I'm like fake yeah dude I've been to the
Griffith Observatory in LA yeah it's
kind of it's fun I love that place it is
cool but when you take those films
people take these really amazing photos
of like looking up with the you know the
observatory and like looking down on LA
and then people see that and they
imagine actually no no you never see
Instagram reality and the subreddit
there was one viral post where this
woman they're in and it's a tunnel that
goes through an aquarium mm-hmm and
she's doing these weird things with her
arms like this like her arms was moving
slowly and the guys filming it because
then they make this video for Instagram
where it's playing that this ambient
music like wow and she's like holding
her arms up and looking out the fish
around her yeah it's fake when you
actually look at what she's doing she's
a weirdo yeah so you have these two moms
in this commercial and they're like how
is she there and they're looking at this
fake photo right and then it literally
shows her posing and trying to get into
the right position yeah to make it seem
like she's doing something exciting
right it's like dude I'll tell you what
that lady at the beach pretending to be
living this great adventure is gonna be
60 or 70 and she's gonna be living under
a bridge and you're gonna have a kid
who's gonna be alike hey mom I got you
chocolates for Mother's Day well that is
an interesting commentary because it
does start with this lady making this
pose and she's telling her friend what
to do to make her look good it's really
fake it's obviously poses obviously
stilled it's just a highlight reel
somebody else's life think about
Gary this is that the message of that
video is these two women are being
tricked into regretting their children
by a woman posing for a fake Instagram
reality photo I don't like that me
neither that's creepy dude you know it's
stuck in my head I was like what did I
just watch
because I was I I don't watch TV ever
but I stayed in a hotel for the past two
nights because I was driving here no no
do pop hit the button and like just TV
I'm like what is this what is this I
actually saw watch professional bowling
for a bit
oh nice because random I like bowling
anyway I found that commercial I was
like oh my goodness but it reminds me it
reminds me of like if you've ever seen
that Michelle wolf show on Netflix where
yeah so that her show yeah okay so this
there's like something happening where
they're chasing after this fake version
of what people actually want there was a
survey done they asked people what would
define success to them guess what the
number one response was they were at
this with the rest how would if how
would you define personal success for
you I'm inclined to either go a big bank
account or family family was number one
family was number one they said how
would you define how do you think
society define success probably the bank
fame Oh fame all right
yeah and women were more likely to think
oh it's much more important that I have
a lot of money it's much more important
that I look like that's funny I had a I
had a friend who was dating this girl
and they came over to hang out and she
asked me what I what I do you know and I
was like oh you know I'm I'm gonna I'm
this was about you and we were doing the
fusion thing right I was like um couple
years ago I'm gonna try to do this
YouTube show and she goes oh how many
followers do you have
I'm like why does that matter
like I don't care if I mean star I mean
it doesn't doesn't matter how many
photos I have me you know she goes and I
look and she shows me she goes I have
7,000 followers I'm like okay cool see
women that's what the cool followers I
don't know strange to me what does it
mean you know you know and she didn't
look anything like her pictures on
Instagram of course she you know I'm
like wow she was showing me like look
see she like was proud to show me her
7005
and I was like okay cool it's so fake
yeah this is what what really bothers me
by people who constantly want to come on
like my channels yeah first of all this
is the podcast for that you don't I mean
so they're like my two main channels I'd
basically never have people on it's me
talking about stuff yeah and you know
all it really is is instead of building
up yourself mm-hmm instead of doing your
show you think other people will give it
to you give it to you that's that same
mentality so me me me me
right and so for me I'm like why do I do
this
I like it yeah I like waking up I like
complaining you know I mean whinging and
so I wake up and I read a story and I'm
like well this makes me makes me mildly
perturbed I believe I will complain
about it and I'd like people to listen
and so I've made a career out of it yeah
but other people are like I know I can
do this because tim has a bunch of
followers I can go on his show and it's
like dude that's not the point
yeah that's why I get you know I get
people hitting up all the time mm-hmm
being like will you reach out to Joe
Rogan for me
no I'm gonna do my thing in my business
how would you do that it's it but
there's people that have been on the
show have something to say so far you
know it's like when it been good guests
I've enjoyed the shows we have stuff to
talk about I want to show and I'm not on
it for those wonders yeah the people who
have come on it's been because there's
been like I something I wanted to talk
about so exactly we're looking at like
paranormal researchers like legit ones
from universities I'm really excited
about it's gonna be awesome
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you